- Welcome back, y'all.
Our next guest is a super
talent singer/songwriter
whose latest album is an
ode to these autumn months
when the leaves are turning
and change is in the air,
especially in his hometown in New England.
That album is called Stick
Season, and it's out now.
Joining us amid his
sold-out nationwide tour,
performing "Northern Attitude,"
give it up for Noah Kahan.
(audience applauds)
(gentle thoughtful music)
♪ Breathing in ♪
♪ Breathing out ♪
♪ How you been ♪
♪ You settled down ♪
♪ You feeling right ♪
♪ You feeling proud ♪
♪ How're your kids ♪
♪ Where are they now ♪
♪ You build a boat ♪
♪ You build a life ♪
♪ You lose your friends ♪
♪ You lose your wife ♪
♪ You settle in to routine ♪
♪ Where are you ♪
♪ What does it mean ♪
(moves to upbeat rhythmic music)
♪ If I get too close ♪
♪ And I'm not how you hoped ♪
♪ Forgive my northern attitude ♪
♪ Oh, I was raised out in the cold ♪
♪ If the sun don't rise ♪
♪ Till the summertime ♪
♪ Forgive my northern attitude ♪
♪ Oh, I was raised on little light ♪
(moves to gentle thoughtful music)
♪ You bought some ♪
♪ You searched online ♪
♪ You're getting lost ♪
♪ You're getting high ♪
♪ All alone, late in life ♪
♪ Scared to live, scared to die ♪
♪ You build a boat ♪
♪ You build a life ♪
♪ You lose your kids ♪
♪ You lose your wife ♪
♪ You settle down ♪
♪ You're feeling lost ♪
♪ You're getting stoned ♪
♪ Then kicking rocks ♪
- Three, four!
(moves to upbeat rhythmic music)
♪ Uh, yeah ♪
♪ If I get too close ♪
♪ And I'm not how you hoped ♪
♪ Forgive my northern attitude ♪
♪ Oh, I was raised out in the cold ♪
♪ If the sun don't rise ♪
♪ Till the summertime ♪
♪ Forgive my northern attitude ♪
♪ Oh, I was raised on little light ♪
(gentle guitar strumming)
♪ If I get too close ♪
♪ And I'm not how you hoped ♪
♪ Forgive my northern attitude ♪
♪ Oh, I was raised out in the cold ♪
(audience applauds)
- All right, one more time
for Noah Kahan, everybody.
His new album Stick Season is out now.
Get yourself a copy.